[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what you're looking
at right here is
my brand new game--
ready to hit the charts-- called
"Guess My Number." This
is a fascinating,
thrill-a-minute game where the
computer thinks of a number and
I try to guess what it is.
Along the way, it gives me hints
as to whether the number
should be higher or lower than
my previous guesses.
So you might be thinking
to yourself as I'm
playing this, wow.
This looks really boring.
Well, it might be.
But what if it looked a little
something like this?
Eh?
I've got a little personalized
welcome message here on the
front screen.
I've got some achievements
now, that I can earn.
As you can see, I'm already
earned my first time
achievement.
And I am 22% of the way towards
completing my 100
guesses achievement.
And when I play a game, you'll
notice that it's telling me
the number of games I have
played so far on this
difficulty level.
And this is being loaded
from the cloud--
ooh.
So I can play on different
devices, and I can see this
number carry over from
device to device.
In addition, I have leaderboards
now for each
difficulty level.
Here we can see that I am in
first place out of all the
people in my circles to
play this game, which
is really just me.
But I'm also second place in
the public leaderboard.
And all this, by the way,
is cross platform.
So on the Android version of
"Guess My Number," I could
earn progress towards these
very same achievements.
And I could compare leaderboard
scores against my
friends no matter what
device they're on.
And when I'm all done playing
a game, I have a brag button
that I can click which will
share my score on Google+.
And anybody that clicks this
little Play button here in my
post will be taken to the very
same game, on the very same
difficulty level, with the very
same secret number, to
see if they can guess it in
fewer moves than I did.
So clearly, now we've gone from
a boring old guessing
game to what I am sure is going
to win several game of
the year awards in the category
of games where you
have to guess a random number.
So let's look at adding
these features--
achievements, leaderboards, save
game in the cloud, adding
interactive posts on Google+--
to your own iOS game.
And we can start by taking this
very same sample game--
and yes, I'm going to share this
awesome source code with
you-- and build it up from
the very beginning.
So stick around.
This is going to be fun.
And hopefully when we're all
done, you'll have learned a
little something about
adding play game
services to your own game.
So I will see you in
the next lesson.
[MUSIC PLAYING]